justice de vesoul comme attendu le
verdict est repoussé à samedi la journée
vient de s'achever par deux heures de
plaidoiries intense pour les parties
civiles
c'est une famille qui se battait pour
une autre famille
c'est la famille portejoie qu'on a qu'on
a un peu adopté et qui s'est battue pour
toute la famille fouille on a pu avoir
toutes ces démarches
tous ces actes de magistrature pour
avancer et tous ensemble et bien on a
décidé de participer parce qu'on en
avait besoin
parce qu'on voulait des réponses et que
c'était en attendant assis sur une
chaise
on va trouver les réponses dans la
soirée les quatre avocats de la famille
se succèdent à la barre m portejoie
évoque notamment le sang froid et le
cynisme donc je n'atteins d'aval a fait
preuve après avoir tué alexia il demande
aux jurés une décision à la hauteur de
la souffrance de ses clients on attend
une décision juste on attend une
décision équilibrée
on attend une décision que l'on pourra
comprendre qu'ils nous projettera vers
le futur
le projet travers culture car il ya un
avant et un après procès pénal on attend
édition que l'on pourra oui à la hauteur
de nos souffrances mais c'est à l'avocat
général de mettre en équation et de
proposer une peine ils correspondent à
nos désirs
ce samedi jour du verdict isabelle
fouillot apparaît fébrile mais soulagé
les plaidoiries de la défense dont clore
une semaine très éprouvante savais pas
ce que c'était qu'un procès mais c'est
tellement intense ou maintenant j'en ai
tourné la page
vous appréhendez un petit peu fait dorer
de la défense aujourd'hui quand même
évidemment tout ce que je souhaite ce
qu'il ne massacrera laetitia jonathan
d'apple devrait être fixé sur son sort
dans la journée il encourt la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité